the nonprofit Children's Health defense
which warns of the possible dangers
posed by vaccines used to receive a
modest 119 000 monthly visits to its
website when kovid happened public
skepticism of the medical establishment
exploded and the site's web traffic went
wild peaking at 5 million monthly visits
so who's behind this group that warns of
the dangers of electromagnetic radiation
and the global cabal attempting to ban
meat the group's chairman chief legal
counsel and highest compensated officer
is Robert F Kennedy Jr who has moved out
of The Fringe after launching a long
shot bid to become president of the
United States RFK Jr is not worthy of
The Rehabilitation tour he's been
getting from pundits podcasters and Tech
luminaries he's built a career as a
professional contrarian he pushes
tabloid Quality Reporting and he wildly
extrapolates from Little grains of Truth
he frequently implies that the
establishment is corrupt at best evil at
worst and he Winks at the existence of
Puppet Masters pulling the strings of
major instead institutions his
organization Children's Health defense
gives opponents of vaccine mandates and
government overreach a Bad Name by
lumping us together with anti-vaxxers
that's why most of the polio today 70 of
the polio today is vaccine polio that
came from the vaccines by the way eighty
percent of the polio cases on Earth
today according to the who are vaccines
trained polio that means people got it
from vaccinated people in 2022
Children's Health defense made the same
point in a peace headlined polio why
vaccines are to blame for Rising number
of cases it claimed that cases have been
on the rise globally since 2016 and the
Resurgence is related to the use of
vaccines actually Global polio cases
fell by 99 between 1988 and 2022 and
were extremely close to eradication
thanks to vaccines what Kennedy said is
technically true but misleading he is
referring to polio spread through
untreated sewage by a form of the
vaccine that uses live virus not only
has that version of the vaccine been
retired but it can only cause an
outbreak in unvaccinated communities
such as some Hasidic neighborhoods of
New York City and outlying areas in one
ultra-orthodox community in Rockland
County a voluntary vaccine Drive mostly
solved the problem for the last 18 years
Kennedy has been a leading figure in the
anti-vaxx movement a principle objective
is that vaccines
um in the childhood vaccines are immune
from pre-licensing safety testing
pharmaceutical drugs are now the third
biggest killer in America after
um after a heart attacks and cancer
um no I do not intend to make it easier
to get drugs to Market this is a
rhetorical ploy to make his vaccine
fear-mongering sound reasonable the Food
and Drug Administration is if anything
overly cautious with vaccine testing
bringing a vaccine to Market generally
takes 10 to 15 years and costs several
billion dollars it's ridiculous to argue
vaccines are insufficiently tested oh if
the 72 when I I was a kid I got three
vaccines
my children got 72 doses of 16 vaccines
RFK is playing fast and loose with the
numbers about 30 doses around the
childhood immunization schedule with
fewer required to attend Most states
Public Schools the reason he didn't get
vaccines that prevent measles and mumps
when he was a kid is that they didn't
yet exist which is a shame because
they've mostly eradicated those serious
diseases in the U.S beginning in 1989
we experienced that chronic disease
epidemic in this country
it is unlike anything in history I mean
neurological disease that I never saw
when I was a kid ADD ADHD special a
language like text Tourette Syndrome
um ASD autism narcolepsy all of these
sunlight autism rates went from one in
ten thousand to one in every 34. peanut
allergies suddenly appeared food
allergies eczema suddenly appeared
anaphylaxis and Asthma you know which
had been around but it exploded he's
correct that food allergy asthma and
childhood obesity rates are increasing
but there's no evidence that's caused by
vaccines RFK is once again flubbing the
particulars in order to pin blame on a
single culprit Kennedy frequently
mistakes correlation for causation gets
the numbers totally wrong and portrays
complex Trends as simpler than they
really are with easily identifiable
villains last year he produced the
documentary infertility a diabolical
agenda it was directed by Andrew
Wakefield the British Doctor Who wrote a
1998 article in the Lancet presenting
evidence that vaccines cause autism
yesterday a respected British medical
journal retracted a study that said the
MMR vaccine May trigger autism over the
past 12 years the science used to back
up his conclusions has also been
discredited with more than 25 other
studies finding no link between the
vaccine and autism Kennedy has
frequently pointed to the Marisol a
preservative that's Mercury based and
was removed from vaccines out of an
abundance of caution back in 1999 as the
main culprit for increasing autism rates
but the Marisol has been removed from
many childhood vaccines since then and
we haven't seen autism rates Trend
downward because of vaccine skepticism
which Wakefield and Kennedy helped Stoke
a measles outbreak in 2014 and 2015 and
one in 2019 were caused by a drop in
vaccination rates as for the film that
Kennedy and Wakefield collaborated on it
recycles long debunked myths from the
90s that tetanus vaccines administered
in Kenya were deliberately laced with a
hormone blocker that caused infertility
this they say is part of the World
Health organization's depopulation plot
but the Catholic Bishops who are the
source for that claim never presented
conclusive evidence Libertarians who
understand the incompetence of
government entities should be more
skeptical that the World Health
Organization would be so effective at
carrying out its nefarious scheme
Kennedy has chaired Children's Health
defense for the last eight years
speaking at events all over the country
on its behalf he used his famous last
name to add the veneer of respectability
to the anti-vaxx cause in fact he's been
focused on this single issue for decades
now in 2005 he first became obsessed
with the preservatives and vaccines
writing an article for salon on the
danger of vaccine additives that needed
five corrections appended to it and was
later retracted by alleging a link
between Autism and the preservative
Ethel Mercury but what do you think
happens when you get an office like if
you're you're talking about your uncle
who's assassinated and you believe the
intelligence agencies were part of that
what happens to you
well I gotta be careful
and I'm aware of that and I'm not you
know I
I'm aware of the of that danger he's
actually not a persecuted truth-teller
although recent attempts to go after
Rogan for having him on or to cut him
out of public debate feed that myth the
real issue is that RFK Jr's bold claims
don't hold up to scrutiny even when
examined by people who don't have a dog
in the fight so what would RFK Jr be
like as President part of his appeal to
Libertarians at least is that he's
staunchly anti-war and a huge critic of
coveted lockdowns and mandates but he's
fundamentally a big government liberal
he supports Alexandria ocasio-cortez's
Green New Deal he favors heavy-handed
government intrusion in the realm of
Environmental Policy he's anti-nuclear
energy he wants pharmaceutical companies
to burn in hell and he seems to believe
in an almost Alex jones-esque dramatized
concept of the deep State he also favors
massive wealth redistribution I don't
think he's huge disparities and Wells
are healthy for our country or healthy
for democracy he correctly points out
that government and big business have an
Unholy Alliance the CIA is ultimately
working for industry like the oil
industry the coal industry and the
military contractors I mean USDA is run
by Cargill Smithfield I'm on Santo I'm o
Pilgrim John Tyson but he doesn't
understand that too much regulation is
the root cause he just thinks large
companies are inherently bad he says
he's concerned about government spending
and throws out wild figures to make his
point we've spent 16 trillion on the
lockdown we wasted and got nothing for
it
8 trillion on the Ukraine war that's 24
trillion dollars that they had to print
to pay for nothing but he's actually no
better than any establishment republican
or democrat in his unwillingness to
scale back Elder Care entitlements that
are actually responsible for driving the
federal government into bankruptcy I
would say it's a red line for me to
touch Social Security or Medicare what's
surreal about Libertarians and
conservatives now embracing RFK Jr is
that he's publicly fantasized about
jailing his political opponents and
cracking down on free speech for years
but the people's climate March in 2014
Kennedy said this who I think they
should be in jail I think they should be
enjoying three Hots and a cot at the hay
with all the other war criminals who are
there do I think the Koch brothers
should be prosecuted for reckless and
dandrin absolutely the First Amendment
does not protect fraudulent speech if
you're if you say something that is
fraudulent you're not protected it just
seems like that way Madness lies because
the government will always come up with
a free text for saying your speech is
not just wrong it's criminal and you
need to be shut down
and judges make decision about what's
fraudible all the time
he's not a real free speech Advocate and
he's not especially thoughtful about the
principles or people he endorses after
all this is a man who once seeped Praise
on the Socialist dictator Hugo Chavez
touting his bogus literacy programs and
commitment to democracy so what would
RFK Jr do in the White House and is it
fair to hold 15 year old sound bites
against him as some of his fans that
I've sparred with have claimed one thing
I'll say for RFK Jr is that unlike most
politicians he's been extraordinarily
consistent in his views he thinks the
world is divided into heroes and
villains and he makes wild unsupported
claims that portray things as simpler
than they really are the difference is
that he's no longer a widely ignored
crackpot Environmental Lawyer he's
asking you to vote him into the White
House